bonjour pierre tattevin merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin sur
rtl france alors on a vu la situation
est critique par rapport aux variants
delta dans les pays d'asie du sud-est
s'est pas encore le cas en europe qui
poursuit ses mesures de déconfinement
est-ce qu'on a raison continuez
justement le desserrement de ces mesures
quand on voit que le variant delta fait
quand même 25 % des cas de contamination
aujourd'hui en france alors
effectivement la proportion du variant
augmente mais par contre le nombre de
cas en france reste très bas on est
vraiment une forte décélération depuis
plus d'un mois maintenant donc savard
est pas fou de lever les progressivement
les mesures mais il faut vraiment qu'on
améliore la couverture vaccinale 1 c'est
vraiment la crise du problème mais c'est
vraiment le ratio personnes vaccinées
qui fera que finalement ce marion delta
ne sera pas aussi aussi tueur si je puis
dire que que précédemment lorsqu'on
n'étaient pas vaccinés oui oui si on
regarde ce qui se passe au royaume-uni
cas de l'invention nous irons de l'avant
ce à la fois sur le nombre de gens
vaccinés mais aussi sur la reprise du
variant delta qu'a commencé il ya
plusieurs semaines chez eux
on voit bien que la grande majorité des
gens qui sont ce variant sont des gens
qu'on pas eu les deux doses donc on
garde la certitude que les deux doses de
vaccin permettre de protéger contre on
se mariait et et on est dans le même
temps on le voit que la vaccination
commence à traîner un petit peu effet
effet des vacances les jeunes aussi sont
incités à se faire vacciner
on les campagnes et les rendez-vous sont
de plus en plus disponibles c'est ce
problème de comment
comment convaincre encore les rétracte
les récalcitrants qui qui pose problème
aujourd'hui et on arrive à ce qu'on
attendait on savait pas qu'elle ment ça
arriverait mais le moment où tous les
gens qui voulaient être vaccinés l'ont
été et maintenant il faut essayer
d'augmenter la couverture vaccinale en
expliquant bien à ceux qui n'ont pas
encore été parce qu'il voulait pas que
c'est tout bénéfique pour eux également
eh ben c'est bénéfique aussi pour les
personnels des ehpad ans l'a vu de morts
qui sont a priori des personnes qui
avaient aussi des comorbidités qui sont
décédés en ehpad alors qu'elles étaient
vaccinés la vaccination du personnel
soignant et des ehpad
est-ce que faut il faut que la
vaccination soit obligatoire pour ces
personnes selon vous qui sont en contact
évidemment avec des malades
c'est pas moi qui fait les lois mais
c'est vrai que ça commence à devenir une
question cruciale parce qu'on ne peut
pas confier les personnes âgées à des
soignants qui représente un risque pour
les pour les personnes âgées parce
qu'ils ont paru lui est de vacciner
c'est quelque chose de difficile à
accepter a expliqué lise on dit que
c'est difficile à accepter l'italie a
mis dehors des personnels soignants qui
n'étaient pas vaccinés est ce que c'est
un exemple à suivre
ce serait beaucoup mieux si on arrive à
convaincre les gens que c'est mieux
d'être vaccinés mais si on n'y arrive
pas il ya cette possibilité qu'il faudra
pas écartée on est responsable la santé
des gens la politique finalement de
l'imposer non oui et c'est quand même un
constat d'échec normalement on devrait
pouvoir expliquer à des soignants que
c'est mieux d'être vacciné et que ça
fait partie de leurs obligations
professionnelles sans le faire passer au
statut d'obligation
il ya un effet pervers aux tests pcr qui
sont gratuits en france la plupart des
jeunes se disent je vais aller faire un
test pcr ça m'évitera d'aller me faire
vacciner
à chaque fois que
il risque de se retrouver en groupe
alors est-ce qu'il faut rendre les pcr
payant c'est aussi dans les tuyaux
ouais non ça je suis pas très fort je
pense que l'accès à la santé en france
il n'a pas conditionné par la part des
secondes 1 par les ressources
je pense qu'il faut mieux faire la
pédagogie et puis que les jeunes en
auront marre de se faire tester toutes
les semaines à chaque fois qu'ils
veulent aller dans des endroits publics
bien sûr que c'est pas très agréable le
test pcr une autre question le test pour
savoir combien est-ce qu'on va était
exposé aux côtés de c'est le cas de
beaucoup de jeunes pour savoir si on a
des anticorps qui lui est payant il
coûte quand même 40 euros est ce qu'il
ne faudrait pas le lefel le rendre moins
cher est en tout cas plus facile plus
facile d'accès aux jeunes qui pourraient
n'avoir qu'une dose mais qui ne le
savent pas c'est une des choses qui ont
été discutés par la haute autorité de
santé ça pourrait fort et que ce soit
encadrée parce que ça représente quand
même de l'argent entre près que les gens
s'amusent à faire un test par semaine
mais de dire chacun droite est gratuit
avant de se faire vacciner une dose une
dose ça paraîtrait effectivement
raisonnable est-ce qu'on reste qu'on
arrive à quantifier d'ailleurs toutes
ces personnes qui ont été positifs
finalement et et qu'ils sont a priori en
partie immunisés est ce qu'on arrive à
avoir un chiffre fiable
oui alors il ya eu 10 mg kg et
régionales et puis surtout ça change
tous les trois mois évidemment est ce
qu'il ya des gens qui perdent leur
dompteur des gens qui les retrouve mais
on est à entre 10 et 20% de la
population en france qui a déjà fait la
couv id est ce que vous pensez que le
fait qu'on ouvre de nouveau le pays au
tourisme est une bonne chose quand on
sait que de toute façon il y aura ce
qu'on appelle une quatrième vague à
cause du variant delta oui je pense
qu'il faut garder les bonnes mesures
mais il faut reprendre une vie plus
normale et que la quatrième vague peut
être très très bas si on arrive à bien
activer les gens parce que finalement le
variant est très contagieux on ne sait
pas s'il est très agressif par rapport
au précédent
ça veut dire qu'on peut être contaminée
sans pour autant engorger les urgences
c'est là le tout l'enjeu oui et puis les
gens vaccinés sont probablement très peu
contaminé aussi donc ne joue plus de
rôle de transmission c'est vraiment la
clé du succès
et on verra si ça réussit donc merci
beaucoup en tout cas pierre tattevin de
toutes vos explications ce matin sur la
propagation du variante delta merci